hey guys i am in brisk new york right
now i am doing the debut
show of greg gutfeld's new show gutfeld
with an exclamation point
tonight on fox news that's right he's
going to five days a week to compete
with
colbert and the other guy and the one in
blackface and that other guy and blah
blah blah
anyway i wanted to do a quick video for
you because there was an extraordinary
hit piece
on florida governor ron desantis last
night on 60 minutes
and what we're going to show you here is
video from the daily caller they're
gonna start
with what 60 minutes showed of ron
desantis implying that he was doing some
sort of pay for play
scheme related to giving out coveted
vaccinations and then
daily caller actually does the work and
they show you the full
answer and you'll see that he did no
such thing and even publix
which is what this whole thing is about
publix the drug store the chain
they've even come out with a statement
saying that desantis did nothing wrong
but you know i always talk about the war
on reality here and it's like if you
only watch 60 minutes and you only watch
mainstream
media then you're stuck thinking
something that is completely untrue
is actually true so i wanted to do this
video
so that maybe you guys could share it
and we can keep waking up some people
anyway have a great day everybody and
remember gutfeld with an exclamation
point
tonight on fox news
we wanted to ask governor desantis about
the deal but he declined our request for
an interview
we caught up with them south of orlando
publix as you know
donated a hundred thousand dollars to
your campaign
and then you rewarded them with the
exclusive rights to distribute the
vaccination
so first of all that what you're saying
is right how is that not paid that's a
fake narrative
i met with the county mayor i met with
the administrator i met with all the
folks at palm beach county and i said
here's some of the options we can do
more drive-through sites we can give
more to hospitals
we can do the publics and they said we
think that would be the easiest thing
for our residents
but melissa mckinlay the county
commissioner in the glades told us
the governor never met with her about
the public's deal
the criticism is that it's paid a place
it's wrong it's wrong it's a fake
narrative
i just disabused you of the narrative
and you don't care about the facts
because obviously i laid it out for you
in a way
that is irrefutable and so it's clearly
not isn't there
no no no you're wrong you're wrong
you're wrong
so first of all that what you're saying
is wrong that's that that's a fake
narrative
so first of all when we did the the
first pharmacies that had it were cvs
and walgreens
and they had a long-term care mission so
they were going to the long-term care
facilities
they got vaccine in the middle of
december they started going to the
long-term care facilities
the third week of december to do ltc's
so that was their mission
that was very important and we trusted
them to do that
as we got into january we wanted to
expand the distribution points
so yes you had the counties you had some
drive-through sites you had hospitals
that were doing a lot
but we wanted to get it into communities
more so we reached out to other retail
pharmacies publix
walmart obviously cvs and walgreens had
to finish that mission
and we said we're gonna we're gonna use
you as soon as you're done with that for
the publix
they were the first one to raise their
hand say they were ready to go and you
know what we did it on a trial basis
i had three counties i actually showed
up that weekend and talked to seniors
across four different publics
how was the experience is this good
should you think this is the way to go
and it was a hundred percent positive so
we expanded it
and then folks liked it and i can tell
you if you look at a place like palm
beach county
they were kind of struggling at first in
terms of the senior numbers
i went i met with the county mayor i met
with the administrator i met with all
the folks at palm beach county and i
said
here's some of the options we can do
more drive-through sites we can give
more to hospitals
we can do the publix we can do this they
calculated that 90 percent of their
seniors live within a mile and a half of
a publix
and they said we think that would be the
easiest thing for our residents
so we did that and what ended up
happening was you had 65 publics in palm
beach
palm beach is one of the biggest
counties one of the most elderly
counties
we've done almost 75 percent of the
seniors in palm beach and the reason is
because you have the strong retail
footprint
so our uh whey has been multi-faceted
it has worked and we're also now very
much expanding cvs and walgreens
now that they've completed the long-term
care mission yes
and it's wrong it's wrong it's a fake
narrative i just disabused you of the
narrative
and you don't care about the facts
because obviously i laid it out for you
in a way
that is irrefutable and so it's clearly
not
no no no you're wrong you're wrong if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell